at the end of the day you know i'm happy
to
you know be in it and uh you don't have
ice
how do you know i have ice cream we
don't you've never had ice cream our
fridge is from the 1980s how do you know
why do you need ice i was going to make
another cocktail yeah then i i yeah
well you keep let me just because i you
know i'm not drinking a vodka hot soda
[Laughter]
yeah how do you not have [ __ ]
hold on no no i feel like i learned
everything i need to know about you guys
when you wake up and you want to drink
you just go i guess i'll have lukewarm
water yeah okay so well here's a little
note stop friend
just stop friend i want you i want to
stop you in your tracks right now okay
okay
we have um rituals that we have in this
house okay and what you're implying
three tools rituals
all right
all right
let me say this yeah i'm trying can you
make this quick i want to use this
all right my girlfriend and i right we
love cold beverages oh really yeah yeah
yeah
can you put everything in the [ __ ]
refrigerator
yeah yeah i can't believe you don't like
that
do you realize that would be a game
changer but we're also
whoa dude i don't like the way you said
that
yeah she's asian dude
um she's just mixed with a little bit of
french the other part bobby he's half
egyptian
is that for real half filipina i love
egyptians i'm amanda med shout out to
you my friend
wherever you are
whatever desert you're hanging out in
right now he's in the middle east by the
way i'm not saying that as a racist
thing
he's actually out in abu dhabi or
something so whatever desert you're in
not a racist thing um god bless you and
take care okay this should be an
interesting cocktail
someone want to go to my sister's house
and get ice
is it far it's a block away
you know i'll tell you another
thing is is that we just don't use ice
because i don't drink you know that
right no but you drink fluids yeah yeah
yeah but you know we so we what we do is
this okay just hear me out okay what we
do is we buy a bottle of water like this
okay yeah and then we stick it in the
refrigerator the refrigerator i don't
know if you know how it works but you
start making ice maybe yeah it chills
are you sure there's no ice in there
there's no eye sweetening we've never
had ice
we haven't made ice in five years yeah
do you understand yeah that half of your
listeners right now are going hold on
you guys don't have i like that's like
when you finally get it it feels like
such a treat like when i go to my
sister's house
it's the art of withholding she's from
the philippines so when i go get to my
sister's house my the first thing i go
to is her crushed ice ice machine yeah i
can't even say that yeah you've never
seen the most delicious thing ever and i
sit there and i just crunch ice for like
hours all right yeah yeah you know you
can have that every day right
yeah yeah bobby there is actually i
bought all of them i love ice i've had
i've had like three different ice makers
yeah i'm thinking about getting one
installed in my garage
because i want the hardcore like the
crush crush ice right the sonics but
what does ice do
it makes this drink science
science science what it is this is that
what i'm saying is that
i know when you put ice in things it
waters it down
or makes it cold
it just makes it cold yeah yeah if you
drink it quick enough it's cold so that
your tongue doesn't go hot that tastes
like vomit
vodka okay i can't believe i i can't
believe i gotta drink this quickly yeah
i'm gonna get [ __ ] hammered on this
podcast cause i'm trying to taste the
ice yeah yeah let me just say this okay
next time you come over i'm bringing my
own ideas no no no no i don't trust you
yeah yeah i don't trust you that much oh
that's a challenge because let me say
this right now
i'm a man of my word okay okay hear me
everyone back back up all right let me
say this right now [ __ ] you will
have varieties of advice have like eyes
with different like cold grapes
oh we can freeze them yeah no you or
water you can freeze water
[Laughter]
we don't have the ice ice maker thing
cubes the trees
do we get one of those you don't even
have ice maker trays if we had an ice
maker tray we'd make ice [ __ ] nothing
but look it's the old one they are
they're getting our friends with that
fridge freezer top regular what's cold
in there uh
oh yeah
we might have something there we might
have something there yeah go get it yeah
yeah
blueberries
how old are these blueberries uh they're
pretty new they're pretty new yeah
they might be a little frostbitten
though so good luck
yeah yeah
i'll take it you're gonna put frozen
blueberries in there something though i
also have frozen coffee oh my goodness
this is why he would win a race warrior
that's insane race wars this is what
you're doing
it's as cold
yeah all right and flavored
yeah this might be the new thing so
ridiculous right there
all right enjoy your beverage
that's not that bad actually oh really
yeah it's a little blueberry hint that's
actually really good
right i know that jim norton is now
doing a podcast for ufc right with
matthew and yeah and i'm a bigger fan
than david spade
i'm a bigger fan than probably jim
norton
and i did they don't give me nothing
shogun was there too what you don't even
listen to
listen to me right now man i know you
said it
yeah yeah i'm pouring my heart out i
know i'm sorry i'm sorry no no no and
then you go shogun was
there where what was shogun
yeah yeah
look at me okay
this is what's going to stop with you
and i mm-hmm when i'm talking to my
brother
he won't be looking at me and he'll have
be having a conversation
he already knows with an invisible
entity steve i know so i'll be like hey
steve what'd you think of that movie and
my brother would have his head turned
looking at something else going hey man
don't do that to me man
i'll be like
yeah yeah and you'll have a conversation
with somebody else i see you talking to
yourself but i i don't know if you're
psyching yourself up
or if you're actually hearing voices no
he's putting himself in situations yeah
i come up with scenarios in his head
scenarios and i live it out
unfortunately
when i'm talking
every time every time
so it's like he's not listening he just
did it too yeah shogun was there yeah
but i was just talking anyway it's fine
i'm sorry and that's okay you're never
gonna get i'm listening i totally want
to i just don't know what that is okay
because i don't want to bobby i'm
telling you i'm alright
i don't i i i no no no no no no no no no
no i don't cut me off don't don't shut
me down and go you don't have to do it
you don't have to do it because that's
you being fearful you don't want to hear
the end of what i'm saying oh [ __ ] this
one this guy wants to get
confrontational yeah i'll get caught you
want to get confrontational you want to
get give a [ __ ] do you want to get real
i'll paint myself like a [ __ ] orca
and swim in the shark and festival i'll
go mystique i'm not afraid i'll go
mystique you're not going mystery maybe
a jellyfish go inside the ocean hole
you're gonna get so transparent people
can see right ocean horns
uh anyway yeah i'll do i want to do more
live [ __ ] i'm honestly i i have been
very fortunate enough to be
busy and out of town
shooting a lot yeah yeah yeah so and i'm
what are you working on now that's all
that people can watch i'm the new batman
you're the new batman
yeah yeah uh no what i got i got a
couple films coming out
uh what are they well the burning woman
there's one uh there's a oh i'm in super
troopers too oh yeah yeah that's coming
out myself tyler levine and hayes
mccarthy you know hayes i love tyler oh
you guys work together
i love me tyler and hayley i love those
guys yeah too
mccarthy oh i love all three of you the
three of us are uh our evil mounties
we're the bad guys oh that's [ __ ]
amazing and uh and rob lowe is the mayor
of a fictitious canadian town oh wow did
you work with rob yeah yeah nice very
nice guy handsome huh yeah it's handsome
as [ __ ] yeah yeah 64 years old i mean i
[ __ ] believe that you must sleep in a
hyperbaric chamber yeah uh and uh yeah
so i got a couple of you know filmy
films uh coming out we're doing another
season of the show i did last year
called loudermilk which is ron
livingston and myself oh that was good
yeah yeah and i'm doing this and that
and that this and i'm ending up on
things i'm going off to shoot a film uh
in a about a month here um that we're
shooting in georgia and and yeah but i
would love to do forget it i love stop
it that's what you forget what it does
forget [ __ ] gets me all investigated
what do we have time wise
what do we got time wise i don't like
his energy what is the time now
an hour oh we're done
hey i'm gonna be in branson um
[Laughter]
the way we end our show is
we're not ending your [ __ ] show yet
hey i'm the captain of this [ __ ] oh yeah
yeah
okay i love you so much i love you too
i'm a
with my little sticker whale puffer fish
in my where am i oh i was loved and
you're like oh that looks like you're a
pasty fisher
um
unhelpful advice nobody gives a [ __ ] in
your audience to hear about what i'm
doing live anyway right anyway oh well
you know what bobby i'm just gonna [ __ ]
hold on do it
i'm telling you something yeah and
you're gonna listen because i was nice
to you at night go ahead tell me i was
nice
and and all those people didn't even
bother to hang out with you and i hung
out with you right remember that one
time we went down to long beach because
a buddy of mine wanted to meet a girl oh
yeah that was i remember that oh that
was terrible yeah we were good buddies
to him too we just went down to long
beach did you support him because he
wanted to see about a girl what was the
black guy that used to hang out with
belle bottoms all the time yeah yeah
sean sean man yeah he was cool
uh and uh
it was different time than i did and
then one time you invited me to a halo
tournament at your house yeah you
weren't into that i wasn't into that
didn't play halo no he wasn't in his 40s
yet wasn't playing video games hello
[Applause]
good night everybody thanks for
listening to tiger belly i'm will sasso
how many brothers and sisters are there
three brothers and one sister and they
were all there obviously yeah
everyone just devastated
yeah
because i know that i know that i know
that your brother
the one that i met the warlock
uh how is he awarding what did he call
him there's something magical about him
he's like from a different like he's
from doctor strange
oh like he could he can do
and um
you haven't met him you don't know he
has a little [ __ ] ring thing and the
eye necklace and then the cape oh [ __ ]
yeah and so um but what i'm saying is
that he
didn't have a relationship right right
with them either right exactly remember
that yeah i do i do remember that's why
i just said it
i remember yeah
yeah
and so
i mean
did all the kids have that kind of
relationship with their parents at that
point
no
no
when you have five kids you have
different relationships with your kids
okay yeah
i mean this is the way you just talk to
me
i just don't like when people talk to me
like that where do you fall are you um
i'm sorry are you scolding me and like
that's fine i don't know where you're
going through a hard time yeah yeah okay
thank you can you see it a different way
though
let's rewind yeah rewind it to save it
in a different way when you have five
kids one i think when you have five kids
that's better so much better you treat
them differently
don't you think so
yes where are you
where are you from in california
oh it's so um
so some of your some of your siblings
were had a communication that you didn't
have and whatnot yeah where do you fall
i'm the second oldest okay
but my parents never wanted a girl i
don't know if your parents were cool
with you being a girl no my mom
definitely wanted boys but it turns out
i have a six foot tall sister who is
like basically like we both look like
linebackers so she was fine with it and
she put us always like in sports and
stuff so that was her way of coping with
having girls so you're not like a frail
little girl you could take care of
yourself yeah and beat up your boyfriend
if he doesn't take care of you exactly
yeah well exactly oh let me punch him
go ahead
here's the story a long time ago many
years ago right there was a guy named
will sasso that's you okay okay
and he's not fat he's thick that's you
thank you you're welcome it's a true
story so far
yeah yeah keep going big dick
big dick will that's what everyone
called yeah that's what everybody
whale sticker fish dicks right and um he
knew a guy by the name of italian guy
right
crystalia right not a medallion
he's not an italian no he's half he's
have italian a half italian he's got the
italian name right and a kind of
good-looking intrinsically funny guy by
the name of brian callan who used to
work
for mad and that's how you kind of know
him too right as the beginnings of it
right
and at that time their
careers were okay they're you know
they're coming up you know brian's
rebuilding he had his own podcast and he
decides to
you you know
just
we're [ __ ] what are you talking about
no not you coming up was coming up oh
yeah before whitney right when did that
happen before whitney yeah so he was
coming back whitney happened right away
uh while we were doing the podcast
exactly 2012 i understand i'm just going
to i'm paving the story yeah all right
but to say no well he's not here to
defend himself it doesn't matter because
he'll listen to this later internal
stuff come up to me both of these guys
will come up to me and i'll go no
they're not gonna listen to this that's
that's oh they do [ __ ] listen up
don't [ __ ] listen to it and that's
another lie in your [ __ ] time story
time story time story time oh god tell
the story story time i need a second
story
all right oh god i'll just point out the
inaccuracies while you're having to
breathe everybody well anyway we got a
guest too so it's not about us sometimes
yes
it's about a guest that um
i've been looking forward to having and
also um dreading at the very same time
she is sort of like um what a laugh
she's a family she's family but also an
enemy but also love there's a lot pure
love
that but pure love that's how families
are it's really difficult to love family
that's true and we have esther coo here
so give her a round of applause
everybody
and also i've known esther i think i
first saw esther on
last comic standing oh [ __ ] somebody
said hey you're gonna see this korean
chick so i think i youtubed it or
whatever and you told a very funny joke
about barack obama's name and your mom
whatever saying it
and i go oh she's really funny and um i
felt like i was really nice to you when
we first met no or how did we first meet
you were always so nice to me i know
that's real okay
just say it again though you are always
so nice to me
first of all yeah okay well before i
even met you
you heard about me of course i knew who
you were legend mad tv legend
[Laughter]
from watching you on mad tv and not only
that but my little brother yeah we would
always make fun of him because he looked
like you oh really
and so um our family we would all laugh
oh that's nice yeah and then um
because then i thought everything was
cool between us and then you try to
start a war with me
oh [ __ ] on online well you tried to
start a war with me
i remember you said that she doesn't
date asian men
yeah so you you know without even
knowing much more about her you just
assumed she didn't date asian men no i
already write do you date asians well
that's what my joke was about that you
had a problem with on last comic
standing and then you were bitching
about me on opie and anthony and then
they all started making fun of you and
norton was like she's hilarious because
you were like yeah she can't go around
and dissing asian guys and they're like
why not this was my bad no but i [ __ ]
up no no no why no i apologize
when i'm in the wrong i'll apologize no
it was great because then you went on
there exposure it's exposure for both of
us is
yeah at the end of the day you know my
god instinct was right about like
twitter beef is the greatest thing you
can possibly do to your career yeah you
should have just kept going with it you
really should have like blown it up
right some more but i did oh
yeah like korean wars you know
let's see
you you're a great you're spaghetti
bolognese i mean everyone can cook
spaghetti no no don't play
pretty it in fact do you put carrots in
it no i don't know
vienna sausage yeah i put carrots in one
you do yeah is it good that way you're
supposed to i put carrots
down are you supposed to yeah carrots
yeah yeah
just as a base you mean like a mirepoix
wait how do you stew down carrots you
should do it down with celery and onion
to make a mirepoix but how do you i
don't know what mirepoix is
is that in harry potter
it's a dance group
hey everyone we're mirepoix
we're all filipino
do you does that mean they boil it they
just stew it down to create like they
boil the base yeah yeah yeah why don't
you do that [ __ ] i do it i know that i
can't get wow i can't get no mirepoix on
my [ __ ] belly noise
i can't [ __ ] with carrots in my [ __ ] or
what i do with other stuff when i make
you other stuff like the not on and all
that stuff next time you make what else
do you make um i make a lot of stuff for
myself because i cook a lot of filipino
dishes and he doesn't really he doesn't
like filipino he doesn't like good um he
doesn't like yeah like i don't know what
it is
cook with a lot of vinegar all the time
so oh yeah maybe he's not into it maybe
you should cook him some like real
down-home filipinos caldereta yeah like
i would love to be
all right
it's all right you're so angry i'm not
angry
let me say something right you're so
angry that you have one taste
it's like
bulgogi and then it's like without boner
with bone
in a pot on fire
let me say something right now let me
say something to you no no i'm tired of
you no no i'm [ __ ] on my mind i'm
tired of you no i'm tired of you i'm
part of you accusing me of not having
taste
i have a plethora
i have a plethora of tastes yeah tell me
what's your favorite one
let's be real that's the taste right
it's about a little child
yeah but when you see a girl with a guy
like i have to let me ask you this in
this town if you saw
be real
if you were at a restaurant in long
beach whatever i'm out of town oh yeah
because i used to live in long beach
right right
and you saw her walk into a restaurant
holding the hands of another guy
yeah
would you tell me
yeah for sure what if it was another guy
you knew
but you were also friends with yeah if
it was crystalia
not that he would right no that's not
gonna say jason collings
because he lives in long beach yeah
jason is right jason collins right he's
a comic friend i love jason i love this
i want to know what you love right yeah
and he you're at a restaurant he's
holding hands with kalila right
would you tell me
yeah
yeah
yeah i don't like that but would you
tell jason that you told him
this is tough yeah
what do you do you're loyal to both
people right so if jason would do please
don't tell him it'll ruin my career
you know he'll he'll you know i mean
it's not going to be good for me dude
i'll never see her again i would ask
around and pull people and see what even
the engineering is coming out yeah i
would ask a lot of guys what they would
do and then you man
yeah you tell me all right
[ __ ] you man you [ __ ] tell me dude
there's your [ __ ] pole are you in a
[ __ ] poll where you're gonna call
five [ __ ] people you're gonna call
our agent you piece of [ __ ]
you [ __ ] tell me
all right i'll tell you no no don't
don't all right
[ __ ] [ __ ] dude
because let me tell you something right
now if haley was walking in with dalia
or i i don't keep saying i know why did
he want another friend of what we know
uh like michael
noche oh [ __ ] i'll rap magdalena
[ __ ] that guy um
brent brent uh-huh what's his brand um
yeah [ __ ]
right
i would pull bren aside write that in
there
and go hey haley are you still singing
for him
yeah
brent dude dude i go i have to tell him
i'm sorry i have to tell him or you're
going to tell him
i'll give you a day i'll give you 24
hours right
that's it
and i expect everyone in this room to do
the same from this [ __ ] scarlet
wench okay do you mean to say harlot or
carlos i like scarlet wedge though yeah
all right
you know he's good
my birthday last week he he texted me
happy birthday you didn't but it's fine
did you
and he spit in my face don't go lateral
on this don't go lateral let's talk
about [ __ ] anything from you but i
give you stuff i know you do you really
do you're a good guy now
didn't i let you go through my water
bottle
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah i let you go
through the water bubble you have to
feel it and i'm about to eat some of
your wage yeah you can have it yeah i
got your meat over there yeah yeah
is it a classy place your restaurant
yeah it's classy
what do you mean
it's it's clean it's clean you're like
you're an investor you're an investor in
that yeah yeah big time is it off of the
strip or where is it off the street
let's promote it what's it called it's
called jokoy's place
no oh god oh be real is that what it's
called it's called yo
yo jay yeah oh that's cool yeah that's
awesome so it's it's off the strip it's
right by my mom's place she lives out
like out in summerland area she worked
there it's a nice area my mom works
there she really she helps out well she
slices meat oh that's amazing yeah yeah
cool and then i tell her to leave when
the the meats so this is you have enough
stock you can go home this is a family
run establishment my mom does not work
there [ __ ] no why would i why would i
have my mom's slices
at the age of 71. you [ __ ] dick she's
retired okay she walks in like this
demarco sorry free food she does when
her son uh uh i'm sorry so sorry i'm
gonna stand up again yep take a stand
that up all right take a stick take a
knee take a deep [ __ ] [ __ ] sucker let
me say something like okay yes your fake
tooth
that's what you [ __ ] i don't i
know i am i want to tell you something
right now right yes there's a place
called um what's the
house in little tokyo yeah it's the most
successful [ __ ] shabbos place in la
and the parents work that right the guy
that owns it works slices the meat there
yes because he didn't so i saw anybody
yeah but i'm just telling you when you
said it i'm like okay i could believe
that you [ __ ] no
no
no there's a difference between that
family and mine
you want to know the difference yeah
that guy has to [ __ ] work there
that's his paycheck whoa
my mom's retired you know what i would
[ __ ] [ __ ] you let me say this
mom thanks for giving birth to me and
you know what on your 70th birthday
you're hired
go [ __ ] slice meat i wish you know
what i wish upon you now you know what i
wish upon you only one week at this
comedy club
side but let me say something right now
you're just like this [ __ ] nut all right
you don't watch game of thrones it's
[ __ ] silly
all right it's a cultural phenomenon
eric i i i hear nothing talk in the mic
you [ __ ] not so far yeah yeah
[ __ ] you no no no no angry don't get
angry that's how i talk sorry don't
smash i've heard nothing but good things
about it but uh i'm just so far behind
yeah okay and i i like when i watch
shows like that i'd like to binge watch
them all right so how long would it take
for me to start from episode one
all the way through that's what my best
friend can i just say this no i
am so envious
that you [ __ ] martin fink you guys
haven't seen it
because if i was in your thing i'd be so
excited i go oh my god the next three
weeks are gonna be the most amazing
three weeks of my life that's how good
the [ __ ] show is back to back yes so
um what is that you know what and you're
getting like a little your adrenaline
flowing and you're looking at me like
i'm clay guido i'm not all right i'm
your friend you're clay guido whatever
whatever that old man's name is okay let
me say this right now okay
whatever you're going through right now
the adrenaline you want to smash my head
the back of your [ __ ] check that [ __ ]
because let me say something right now
i'm a rage monster too
what does that mean i'll tell you what
that means i'll tell you what that means
chachi okay
all right i have um
hrs oh you know what that is i have no
idea hidden [ __ ] strength oh
you don't think that people with that
[ __ ] or chimpanzees are strong but
they'll break maybe you shouldn't
compare retards to chimpanzees
no in terms of strength those are very
strong animals
my bite's like a hyena is that do i feel
bad about that no
all right your face is like
wow shots fired and you know what that's
a spreadsheet right there
what's the tally right now what that's
like nine spreadsheets all right [ __ ]
i'm gonna tell you right now dude all
right so relax we're good you and i
we're friends all right and also on top
of it i'm not afraid of you and also on
top of that right now is that that's not
what happened
what happened i respect you and i love
you and i'm always going to be on your
corner dude
boom so i have another thing that i'm
concerned about i'm going to just read
you something okay jesus no don't do
that don't check with my publicist first
so you the other last week you go
bobby it's joe cool
just bobby there's personal [ __ ] there's
nothing there i'm not going to read the
whole thing
i would just read this bobby
it's joe i'll edit this out if you don't
want it
no you won't yeah i sort of got it well
you don't even have a proper episode
we're surrounded in sanrio i said i feel
like we're [ __ ]
are you okay
and you go we're better now are you
really concerned yeah jerk how are you
that's [ __ ] rude yeah well you are a
piece of [ __ ] no
you are people you want to see my face
you want to see concerned you want to
see my sir well i'm going to i'm going
to do this okay i'm going to give you a
face concern go
see you're joking around with that even
right there that was good
let me do it again one more time i swear
to god your concern looks like you're
holding it in your own shirt
just hold on
let me try all right
i'm gonna say are you okay
you don't care see no you don't care
give me a shot
give me a shot that's why i asked you
all right that's why i asked you are you
concerned i don't
are you okay no no no no that's even i
think he does that i don't think he does
that yeah yeah who says do stuttering to
make you saying your idea of things to
do that's one thing dude
yes yes
yeah yeah
i'm gonna tell you something right now
my friend okay
there's only a couple of things in life
that you need all right shelter
food and sexualities hey all right
clothing
i'll [ __ ] do this all day all right
bobby i don't give away stop it all
right stop my point isn't this
scratching it is that yes food is a big
one it's another thing all right three
in the morning i can't sleep i feel
dirty should i take a bath or can i go
to a steam room
a really cool korean bath house this is
like some first world problem [ __ ] right
yeah that's what i'm saying is that i'm
not saying listen
i know that in an apocalyptic situation
right we're all [ __ ]
not me
you maybe
that's it that and this is this is why
this is why we're here right now
because that right there is
provocation
is that the right word provocation you
just provoked me i also just wanted
uh no just let me just finish this okay
so in a zombie apocalypse right right
that you think you would live longer
than me
come on come on
come on let's just be do you have
hunting do you have hunting skills i've
i have hunting skills
i mean i'm gonna sweet i'm an athlete
here's the thing if we could both hide
but if i get caught i could actually do
something about it and get away no you
can't call a zombie and then all of a
sudden you're you know man you're trying
to
tie kick zombie kick people
that would be awesome
it doesn't have to be that but i
for for example i can run faster than
you can i'm sure yeah i don't need a run
dude i'm an event
you're gonna live an event yeah
that's where you know where i'm gonna go
i'm gonna go to the mall well this goes
back to the food what are you gonna do
i'm gonna go to west covina mall already
i haven't planned out what happens when
you know this is your plan yeah and i'm
gonna hide in a van and then all of a
sudden i'm gonna like every day i'm
gonna like lock each door i'm gonna try
to kill all the zombies inside then i
would lock all the doors and i would eat
like a um hot dog on a stick all day
okay so what happens about the other
people sounds like dead other people
that that are still alive that you you
can join me if you want to but well no
you'd be joining me i'd be running the
show see that's i don't want to sleep so
wait who is that you know what's up
i'm sorry you want him to bend the knee
i'm not going to bend the knee okay how
do you establish alpha you know what
you're like the [ __ ] what was that
guy the mayor or whatever that was in
walking dead what's his name governor
the governor of the governor you're the
governor you're the bad guy oh wow i'm
the good guy you're right my clan we
farm we love each other you and enslave
that's fine but but rick's also a badass
what do you want me to do
you know what he would do you know what
i know him yeah you know me are the only
humans alone this dude would [ __ ] try
to [ __ ] me no wait you
the only the only asian comics that i
saw that that inspired me because i was
so into comedy was margaret cho and like
henry cho
i can't even remember the ones that i
could see like on like on cable
you know that were coming on frequently
and then when i went to la jolla because
this comic got me he knew the manager
there and got me on and i saw bobby lee
my head blew up i was like oh my god
cause i was weird-looking no you were
funny you're you're a korean you know
what i mean you were like you were you
were like yo this is what was your first
impression of me uh i thought you had
no i don't want to say it yeah yeah that
was [ __ ] no down like yeah a little
bit of that [ __ ] you know what dude
but a lot of people say that no no a lot
of people say i know that one people in
the community a lot of people say i know
but when they say it it really i don't
know why you're laughing george okay
because in terms of whites you're like a
two jesus that's out of a hundred that's
a lot of rights you're the worst you're
like you you you're worth worthless god
okay if you want them to you want them
to stay around and work for you and he
has
syndrome no one is left premium talk
show first of all did you really believe
that i was [ __ ]
i thought you know that's like joke that
is a joke
let me answer the question yeah go ahead
sorry
can i explain myself yeah go ahead
because they don't know they only know
good looking bobby with the good rock
and roll hair
and the missing tooth they only know
that guy
they only know good looking rock and
roll bobby hot hot rock and roll chick
yeah that's all they know yeah yeah you
know what i mean missing tooth
cat hair cat hair and beanie like they
only know that one yeah
onesie shirt onesie shirt all right
that's all they know i know bobby hole
hawaiian shirt and your aqua and and
used to do
let me explain why i thought you had
down syndrome okay go ahead god yeah
yeah let me explain like i'm not just
trying to be funny i know i know you
really we all i thought you had
difficulty
really hurting my feelings okay no
really bobby can i explain okay
so we go to la jolla yeah and the guy
the mc goes oh my god this kid killing
it out here you know what i mean he's
we got to hurry up because
his boss is up
[Laughter]
and then they go bobby lee everybody
crowd goes crazy he's a local favorite
right and then he does this thing where
his eyes are kind of like yeah cause he
was kind of doing a stoner thing yeah
yeah then he had this big like hair and
then he'd move his head
yeah and it took him forever to get to
the microphone yeah and i thought oh
he's he's special yeah yeah but you know
what that's called mugging yeah
i was [ __ ] mugging for the crowd you
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah
yeah but i would go up there right i
would mess up my hair and you know what
my opening line was what i'm not really
asian i just woke up yeah two minute
applause break crushed standing off
standing up
no i'm not even joking two minutes a
[ __ ] applause break i stood yeah how
that's at the [ __ ] first place that
was mirage yeah and then you did you did
uh dolphins
tears i did dolphins and tiger [ __ ] yeah
it made it the mirage yeah you had a
shovel who was it zigfried and roy's
i had to no i had to clean siegfried's
[ __ ]
in order to play with the dolphins oh
right yeah he said
yeah i did you didn't meet zigfried yeah
secret always came through roy never
came through oh really is he nice secret
was is so funny because when you look at
i don't know if anyone gives a [ __ ]
that's listening yeah
but people don't know that people don't
know [ __ ] people don't know that uh
mark wahlberg was [ __ ] marky mark
[ __ ] that's true you called me a gift
to them i don't care
anyway sorry
you're trying to act like this is a
premium [ __ ] talk show you got a
camera got a cameraman in a goddamn car
all right i apologize economic collapse
of you know 708. so then you couldn't
really get into these anyway it was very
it's a great house i was very fortunate
you know i regret even asking it
that's not a really good way to you know
what bobby
i'm going to tell you something you know
i'm going to tell you
was okay we should end it there yeah
yeah yeah because just like you said
you did some 10-minute podcasts and it
inspired you to move forward yeah
perhaps it even happened anyways thanks
will south coming by
everyone clap right now they're not
we'll stop for coming by they're not all
cut it off they're not all home runs cut
it off sometimes people just want to
what eddie shows bobby yeah i'm at the
end of the stereo emperor i just want to
know about the ontario improv this
weekend you want to hear about remember
check it out
i'm also planning to hear about allison
emperor did you get when you get those
papers in right and i want to oh i
understand brian ortega for killing him
you know someone who does you watch mma
you know someone who does uh brick work
[ __ ] he bit he cuz it'll improve the
frankie edgar that's really gonna bring
up the resale value of your house yeah
yeah it's now never a bad idea to put it
in another bathroom beat max holloway
never a bad idea i don't know that i
didn't know you got the crew there
already
you might as well have them come in that
would be a really good thing i've got
peg and groove hardwood that's been
standing at once
sitting underneath it was centered
underneath marble everybody that was a
great hey take a claw hammer take it to
some of your uh off right now some of
you some of your floors
you might find some very expensive wood
under there on instagram
at the tiger belly anything that you
think that someone would take out and
put in another house that's what you're
looking for in your property don't be
afraid to spend the money you're living
in your investment
make sure you check out our sponsor
brooklyn and
brooklyn it's hard to find a place on
your own oh sorry not brooklyn but also
brooklyn and you bought some stuff there
they're brother sponsors but two broke
women
yeah good to have good linens get a
couple and get a get a little cover for
the duvet too just in case things get
saucy with your